I mean you are like literally my number
one I don't know if I should even say
that when will that be anyway say no say
what oh my god your story was so dope
yesterday on snapchat I was loving it
good and you and I we got that heart
fire like maybe you're a little nervous
no no no no it's like trust me
I go on first dates all the time so you
guys ever have any weird celeb run-ins
the time when Deckard saw Clark's rag at
the hotel gym holy hey Clark Clark
wait wait wait wait wait
Kevin's story definitely beats mine
Anthony thanks for sharing your workout
with us
you owe me $12,000 that'll make me
you up hey guys let's wrap this up
complete misunderstanding hey Britney
what about you I've literally never
embarrassed myself oh hey what are you
doing oh just reading a script for this
oh my god is that the new Hunger Games
script cuz you can tell me I won't tell
anyone I think you're thinking Pilate so
Twilight where you have the bow and
arrows so I was in Twilight Kristen
Stewart please Bella yes vampire falls
in love with her and they got ways in
Barrie's
no rake this no no no okay ash can get
weirdly pushy o-m-g you guys it's all of
them brother
I had no idea that little mannequin
could even eat I'm gonna go say hi
sometimes coincidences are so awesome
it's my best friend and my arch-nemesis
it's better than none
do not tell me you two are on a date
nope actually no we're not suggest that
actually we were just on a date until
you just decided to be a dick hole oh
you tell em Bella and frankly I'm
surprised he even has it in him to ask a
lady out seriously I'm not here please
continue or we just make this a nice
romantic three-way never gets old Kevin
that's right oh my god seriously it's
Britney bitch my favorite people oh my
god this is gonna get more violent than
a fast and furious equal this is not
cool man we should just leave I do not
want to watch this
enjoy the rock it's so good to see you
with my friend Christopher hi how was
the whole Hospital thing oh well I'm
proud to say I fully recovered after my
meltdown when you stole those three
endorsements from me Oh whatever was
gonna put a down payment on a condo had
to let that one go I'm a big deal oh my
god you know what bail is perfect for no
the Klan Thor saga adaptation Deckard no
okay just picture her with six wings a
horn that is the ice queen Baratheon why
would I be threatened by you you're an
18 year old with six million Instagram
followers intent of 26 cross-platform
before talking real numbers counting is
tough for you anyway but that's a hot
awkward yeah we hate myself come on
don't do this it's already happening no
no you know this whole thing really
efficiently right you guys should say
I'm gonna go best friends oh hey I
always wonder if I kid around an idea
I'm not threatened by you at all don't
eat the money I'm here popping out of
this orgy because you guys are we should
all just make it a foursome
you're a dick slit yours a caliph and I
just want to be if you're just an
alcoholic and who the are you Bella
you my laughs remember you like my lap
but you're not getting laid tonight